bonjour à tous apple ne supprimera pas
sont encore en haut de ses smartphones
dans cette vidéo je vous expliquer
pourquoi mon avis en tout cas apple ne
supprimera pas son encoches pourquoi ils
vont la conserver et quel sera l'avenir
d'apple
d'un point de vue esthétique encoches ou
pas encore on va regarder ça maintenant
effectivement avec l'iphone disent à peu
la fait beaucoup parler lui ya des gens
qui est beaucoup c'est un coach qui
trouve ça intéressant c'est la patte
c'est une pâte et un certain charme elle
a d'autres au contraire qu'il le détail
ce qu'ils disent mais c'est encore sur
la mode partout elle est dégueulasse je
n'en peux plus de ça tant qu'ange alors
effectivement y aller pour y aller qu'on
montre en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que c'est encore elle a fait des petits
qu'on la retrouve dans de plus en plus
de modèles sur des modèles android
notamment donc voilà donc effectivement
c'est encore aujourd'hui quand l'aide ou
qu'on n'aime pas on est un petit peu
obligé de la subir ya effectivement des
constructeurs comme samsung comme htc
qui ne la met pas qui la mettront à
priori pas il y en a d'autres qui s'y
sont convertis maintenant voilà c'est un
petit peu compliqué de faire son chemin
là dedans one + va mettre une encoche
ans s'envole de +6
il ya plein de marque effectivement
mettre des encoches dont bat donc les
encoches que vous l'aimiez que vous ne
l'ayez pas vous êtes obligés de la subir
et surtout si vous avez un produit apple
si vous voulez rester chez apple
dans la gamme 10 et dans les produits
qui vont arriver il va vous falloir vous
y faire parce que c'est encore elle va
rester elle va rester là et encore un
bon moment
alors effectivement c'est encore celle
arrivée sur l'iphone 10 fin 2010 est
effectivement set en poche elle a ses
détracteurs tout le monde s'y met mais
pourquoi est-ce que plein d'autres
constructeurs mettent cette en cauchemar
pour deux points essentiels le premier
point c'est que malgré tout apple reste
prescripteurs d'en donner le là on est
sûr que les produits apple sont des
produits qui marchent si vous mettez
l'encoche vous suivez le leader en tout
cas le coleader avec samsung et vous
êtes sûr que ça marchera le deuxième
point c'est qu'effectivement en étant
une encoche vous allez utiliser plus
grandes surfaces au niveau de l'écran
donc un écran toujours plus grand
toujours plus optimisée même si comme
avec d'autres produits vous avez la
possibilité de ne pas l'afficher
et vous arrêtez à fleur de l'encoche
pour ne pas avoir effectivement ce petit
démarcations sur votre écran associe une
possibilité alors même si apple n'est
pas le premier à avoir mis ce notch sept
ans cole sur son smartphone il en est
néanmoins le porte flambeau donc c'est
lui en tout cas qui aujourd'hui fait
référence dans ce domaine là alors je
sais vous inquiétez pas je lis tous vos
commentaires et j'ai bien vu
je suis d'accord avec vous apple n'est
pas celui qui a créé l'encoche mais en
tout cas c'est vraiment qu'ils ont
démocratisé au niveau du grand public en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'apple
pour l'instant n'est pas près d'enlever
set en poche ils vont la garder pour
pouvoir intégrer leurs caméras trou
d'aix et profiter d'un plus grand écran
parce que le noise confère une pac une
vraie marque de fabrique à sa gamme 10
et aux modèles qui vont arriver par la
suite et en 2018 ça devrait toujours
être le cas revenir en arrière ça serait
désastreux pour apple ça serait désavoué
leurs produits leurs choix stratégiques
dire que l'iphone dit ce n'était pas
l'avenir le modèle du futur le
smartphone du futur donc il est très
clair qu'apple ne peut pas revenir en
arrière sans risquer de se désavouer de
plus eyeos 11 et probablement ios 12 ont
été conçus autour de 7 ans coche pour
l'iphone dit c'est pour les produits à
venir donc si on veut revenir en arrière
et un falloir déjà d'un point de vue
matériel travail et un autre design ça
ne sent quand même relativement
compliquée et d'un point de vue logiciel
revoir un petit peu la copie
alors effectivement à ios on peut
l'utiliser sur des smartphones qui n'ont
pas l'encoche notamment les 6es 7,7 +88
plus et compagnie mais on voit qu'avec
l'iphone dix on a quelque chose qui est
complètement optimisé avec de nouveaux
gestes avec de nouvelles façons de
fonctionner sur ce smartphone avec sept
ans coche parce qu'on a plus de tschaï
dit on a failli samedi il y à de
nouvelles choses qui ont été mis en
place et il est très clair qu'apple ne
reviendra pas en arrière en revanche
rassurez vous si vous n'aimez pas
l'encoche qu'il est très clair qu'un
jour ou l'autre et encore je vais finir
par disparaître parce qu'une technologie
ont tous une autre alors de toute façon
on va très bien que les smartphones les
iphone comme il était allé porte c'est
le 3gs
il avait un petit peu ce look un petit
peu au losc où ils ont évolué on va
qu'on a eu plein de cloud qu'on a eu des
looks comme le 4 comme ça ou 4s je sais
plus d'être 4s avec ce dos en verre on a
eu la gamme avec
gamme color comme le 5 c il ya à
l'iphone 6 aces mois que j'ai
actuellement qui est caché juste ici
donc on voit effectivement qu'il ya eu
toute une gamme une évolution accède
cette plus wii fit plus avec ces grands
écrans différentes et d'écrans pour
arriver jusqu'à l'iphone 10 l'iphone
plutôt bord à bord avec un grand écran
est de toute façon plus tard il va y
avoir encore une évolution donc sept ans
koch a très certainement être amené à
disparaître alors pourquoi comment
qu'est ce qu'on va retrouver à la place
à mon avis qu'on va retrouver à la place
il va falloir être patient c'est tout
simplement le système d iphone pliable
ce que c'est l'innovation qui devrait
arriver dès 2020 2020-2021 peut-être en
tout cas chez apple ce sont les iphone
pliable cette technologie elle est en
train de se mettre en place tout
doucement très longtemps qu'on en parle
et samsung on en parle de plus en plus
au havre est aussi en train de s'y
mettre
apple va s'y mettre donc ils vous
proposeront un smartphone pliable
pliable à priori à la verticale avec un
écran haut à l'écran bas qu'on pourra
replié sur lui même
bon il peut aussi des parrains deux
possibilités ça c'est des choses qui
vont se voir dans le temps parce que de
toute façon je pense qu'apple va
attendre que ça me saoule sorte son
galaxy 10 son galaxy x pour voir un
petit peu ainsi si ça fonctionne si le
marché prend si le marché est mûr pour
que une fois que le marché sera mûr et
bien en place
apple puisse arriver dessus avec un
iphone pliable et à ce moment là qui dit
iphone pliable et dit forcément quelque
chose de relativement différent et je
serais très surpris kinougarde la petite
encoche pour le fait saliver
on peut très bien imaginer que d'ici
quelques années on est des capteurs qui
soit vraiment intégré à l'écran on peut
imaginer un écran micro-perforé qui
laisserait passer le son du haut parleur
et on peut très bien imaginer également
la même chose pour une caméra trou
d'être complètement intégrée au
smartphone qui du coup ne serait pas
forcément logique euros l'époux est logé
à différents endroits de votre
smartphone pour vraiment quelque chose
d'encore plus précis en termes de
mapping votre visage donc de toutes
façons l'encoche elle est là uniquement
parce qu'on a un haut parleur une caméra
avant une caméra trou d un capteur en
trois dimensions de l'infrarouge et
compagnie demain quand ça ça va
disparaître quand on pourra l'intégrer
complètement à un écran et bien il y
aura plus encore
donc rassurez vous l'encoche aujourd'hui
on la subit quand on n'aime pas d'ici
quelques années il y en aura plus par
contre il faut pas être trop pressé
parce que vous savez que apple est bien
innover
innov à son rythme on prend son temps on
innove un peu comme les suisses on prend
le temps c'est la vanne pour les suisses
je plaisante j'aime beaucoup les suisses
ne vous fâchez pas je viens bientôt chez
vous allez enfin peu importe ça c'est
autre chose on en parlera plus tard
en attendant soyez sûr qu'apple aime
toujours innover menem prendre de moins
en moins de risques parce que prendre
des risques se plante et ça coûte très
cher et c'est très dangereux donc
effectivement apple va prendre son temps
avant de sortir un smartphone pliable
voir un petit peu ce qui se fait du côté
de la concurrence
est ce que ça marche oui non est ce que
tout le monde est convaincu oui non
voilà donc ils le sortiront l'encoche
disparaîtra mais il faut un petit peu de
patience d'ici là l'encoche on va encore
ça tapait si on n'aime pas pendant
quelques années
2018 2019 2020 peut-être même 2021
imagine que des smartphones avec des
écrans sans encoches avec des capteurs
intégrés n'arriveront pas tout seul vous
aurez en parallèle des smartphones des
modèles avec encoches d'envoyer voilà de
toute façon l'encoche on va regarder
encore pendant au moins minimum 5 ans
pour toutes ces raisons apple va
conserver son encoches c'est une marque
de fabrique
il ya une caméra trop deg ce qui marche
très bien qui fait la force de ce
produit et en plus de ça beaucoup de
produits android se met aujourd'hui à
l'encoche qui est en train de devenir un
standard
bien qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
n'aiment pas bien qu'ils aient beaucoup
de détracteurs malgré tout si beaucoup
de constructeurs font les encoches mais
vous pourrez pas y couper tout si vous
aimez les produits des marques comme
apple
one + compagnie qui de toute façon vous
colle des encoches de partout dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous partagiez mon opinion
est ce que vous pensez que l'encoche
chez apple on va la garder encore
longtemps encore minimum 5 ans avant
d'en arriver une nouvelle techno une
nouvelle techno qui pourrait arriver
d'ici deux trois ans de trois ans mais
les modèles avec en poche vont persister
maquis moi tout sans commentaire comme
d'habitude vous invite à ne laisser des
jolies pousse à rester connectés à vous
abonner parce qu'on parlait toujours
plus de techno parler de nouveaux
produits parler de technologie en
elle-même parlait même de judy de
robotique de technologie française de
voir un petit peu ce que la france a
dans le ventre
d'un point de vue technologique votre
vie numérique va ya plein de choses
super intéressantes et plein de
surprises qui vont arriver
donc restez connectés jette à l'essai
des jolies pousse à faire des gros
bisous parce que moi je vous fais aussi
des gros bisous je vous dis à très
bientôt d'ici là soyez sa santé vous
bien et à très bientôt
jobs
[Musique]